[Applause]
[Music]
here on visual politic we've already
made several videos about how Venezuela
is going through its toughest times
however we still need to address one of
the most serious consequences of the
Bolivarian revolution strike ganic
failure and there's no debate here
venezuela is adrift with every day that
passes life in this country
it just becomes harder and harder with
some of the highest violence poverty and
inflation indices in the world and with
a growing drug trafficking and organized
crime industry many many Venezuelans
can't find any alternative to putting
some space between themselves and their
homelands that is leaving behind a
country that's falling apart
Venezuela tiene la Fortaleza social
political militar
well if you were in a situation like
theirs which any of you have any hope I
mean I would certainly try to escape
and that's exactly what more and more
Venezuelans are doing especially the
youngest ones now some of you might be
wondering well okay Simon but how big is
this problem in reality well you see
according to the UN's calculations from
2014 to June of 2018 around 2.3 million
Venezuelans left their country and these
numbers they're not gonna stop from
growing anytime soon
see when a lot of immigrant olive on a
salami merci for Casey an EVO cincuenta
we go there Venice were on the tour
epithalamium assirram in other words the
Bolivarian revolution is caused the
greatest Exodus in the history of Latin
America so listen up
[Music]
the exodus societies are entities in
constant movement throughout history
migration has been continuous whether
for economic or for political reasons to
find better opportunities to escape from
a threat or simply to escape bad living
conditions people are continually moving
from one place to another however an
exodus is something quite different
the term exodus refers to the mass
emigration of people who are forced to
leave the place where they live that is
to say it isn't about people who dream
of a better life but people who have to
leave in order to survive in general
throughout history the most common
causes have been political racial or
religious perhaps the most common type
of exodus throughout history has been
that by people forced to leave their
homes because another stronger group
took over and expelled them violently
for example there's the exodus of the
Armenian people in 1915 when hundreds of
thousands of people were forced to
escape from the Turkish Empire a process
that became known as the Armenian
Genocide another case would be that of
the tens of thousands of Republicans who
faced the threat of reprisal torture and
condemnation of all kinds from the
Francoist sand were forced to leave
Spain after the end of the Spanish Civil
War or what happens in the Second World
War or with the fight for independence
in African and Asian countries in the
1960s
well in our times we've had two very
clear examples the first was a product
of the Syrian civil war which since its
beginning in 2011 has driven millions of
people to move the inside and outside of
its borders the second case is that of
Venezuela and everything indicates that
its exodus will end up being much much
bigger than serious at this moment the
migration of Venezuelans should be
described as a forced migration as it's
not planned it's for survival Beatriz
Borges executive director of the justice
and peace center in Venezuela because
folks we need to understand what's
happening here
understand that the hundreds of
thousands of Venezuelans who are
escaping they don't do it for pleasure
they do it out of necessity and unlike
the examples we've covered here the
Venezuelan exodus isn't the result of a
war or the occupation of a foreign force
but of the hunger fear and the misery
caused by the Bolivarian revolution
you see according to the last living
condition survey in 2018 87 percent of
Venezuelans live in poverty and more
than 60 percent in extreme poverty these
are sub-saharan African numbers
the paradox is that this humanitarian
catastrophe is happening in one of the
most important oil powers in the world
folks the situation is beginning to get
real serious for example due to a lack
of medicine and health equipment within
the country diseases such as measles
tuberculosis and malaria diseases that
had been eradicated in the country
haven't only re-emerged in some cases
they've become real epidemics and what's
more there are more than 100,000
hiv/aids patients at risk due to a lack
of access to necessary medication United
Nations office for the Coordination of
human affairs and of course this lack of
Medicine has lethal consequences for the
population the last model Venezuela is
experiencing such a huge production and
supply problem that it's becoming
increasingly difficult to acquire basic
food products for example the can of
tuna can cost more than a minimum wage
salary the folks explains why according
to data from the United Nations why
deals da da caballo and the rest of the
regime's answer growing fat on lobster
dinners around one and a half million
Venezuelan sir currently suffering from
malnutrition
and then there's the violence issue
which is also no joke homicide
statistics for example are out levels
typical of a country in a civil war
check this out
[Music]
and then there's of course robberies
looting extortion and all the other
crimes that have made this country a
very dangerous place to live and the
Bolivarian police they don't help listen
up more than 40% of the crimes in July
were committed by police officials
Venezuela an observatory of violence so
faced with this scenario we can't be
surprised that just in the last three
years two million Venezuelans have left
the country by sea air and land
surely you've all seen the huge rows of
Venezuelans walking step by step towards
the border because most of those who
flee on foot sometimes take buses cars
mules but lately many have begun simply
walking to Colombia Brazil and Ecuador
first and then maybe from there to Peru
Chile or Argentina and of course this is
not an easy trip the journey is hard not
only because of how tiring it is and
because of what they leave behind
families friends and their homes but in
many cases these refugees fall victim to
fraudsters thieves and other nefarious
characters fortunately so far the other
Latin American countries have shown
great solidarity and have allowed almost
unrestricted entry to the hundreds of
thousands of Venezuelans however this
could all change receiving so many
people at once isn't always easy
especially if the recipients on exactly
rich countries
[Music]
[Applause]
huge pressure
folks it's true some Latin American
countries are beginning to feel a lot of
pressure the venezuelan exodus is so
great that in some cases they're facing
serious capacity problems for example in
the border state of Reimer in brazil the
number of Venezuelans attending medical
centers has increased from 700 in 2014
to more than 50,000 in 2017 just in the
first three months of 2018 the number
reached over 45,000 everyday around
seven to eight hundred Venezuelans
crossed the border and that's creating a
lot of trouble for their vaccination and
organization Michel temer president of
Brazil in Colombia the number of
Venezuelans already exceeds 1 million
people in Peru there are more than
400,000 and in Ecuador it's almost a
quarter of a million the way this is so
big that in 2018 so far more than 4,000
Venezuelans have arrived in Ecuador
every day of course many of them go on
to other countries countries like Chile
which in the first six months between
January and June received almost a
hundred and fifty thousand Venezuelans
all of this is causing the most affected
countries to begin establishing some
measures to reduce this huge flow of
people the Brazilian government for
example has announced the deployment of
the military at the border and just
stated that it will consider
establishing quotas that is a maximum
number of people who can enter the
country for their past Ecuador and Peru
have begun to demand the presentation of
passports and why is that
well that's because passports are not
exactly easy to obtain a Nicolas Maduro
as Venezuela because for one there's a
bureaucratic labyrinth and also the
simple facts that the government lacks
the paper needed to actually print them
oh and then there's also the fact that
because many officials do great business
by selling passports on the black market
where a simple pass forty's official
price is only about the equivalent of 20
cents it can cost between seven hundred
and five thousand five hundred dollars
depending on how quickly you need us or
how much money the buyer has the Fox
News
yeah by a similar face or face look what
yuan Fei mute and for those who are
lucky enough to already have a passport
when it expires they can extend its
validity for two more years with a stamp
because they won't get another passport
but even so getting that stamp unless
you go through the black market can take
up to three months anyway that's the way
things are for the first time Latin
America is facing a serious problem with
its borders and it's not an easy problem
on the one hands you can't prevent
Venezuelans from coming in it's a
humanitarian issue and there's still a
huge margin of refugees to citizens but
it's evident that if things go on like
this more and more people will try to
escape the country and that's quite a
challenge here every latin-american
country needs to work in a coordinated
manner and receive support from the
international community of course to be
fair the effort and solidarity shown by
many of the region's countries has been
extraordinary it's been an incredible
example of that in unity and by the way
one final note here isn't only common
Venezuelans who are leaving in recent
years many Venezuelans who've made a
fortune during the Bolivarian revolution
x' dark variate as well as the families
of many high-ranking officials have also
left and of course they've done it with
a full wallet former ministers of Chavez
hid two billion euros in Andorra
the opulent landing of Venezuelan
millionaires in Spain a dozen
businessman and former top officials
some of them detained for corruption
have invested tens of millions in luxury
real estate and hunting ranches these
are known as bola chicas and we're gonna
try and do a video about them in the
future but for now it's your turn do you
think that the international community
should help the Venezuelan people more
well leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine
also this channel is made possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]